This video is made possible by brilliance.
You'll learn more about brilliant later in today's video,
but if you'd like to learn more about them right now,
I've got a brilliant.org forward slash.
Biographics you'll also find a link in the description below.
Okay.
Socrates is considered the father of western philosophy.
He was a man who questioned everything and everyone with no regard for how his
opinions would be received.
He imposed his views with a dogmatic superiority.
This eventually sealed his fate.
It's still his great legacy to the world was the method of questioning to arrive
at the truth,
which is known as the Socratic method.
Today on biographics,
we're going to discover the man who was Socrates
of all the great figures of antiquity.
None are as frustrating for the historian as Socrates.
The man never wrote down anything that has survived,
so the only records of his life come from secondary sources.
The two main ones are from Plato,
his devoted students and Xenophon.
They contemporary of Plato.
These writings mainly consist of records of conversations that often included
Socrates himself.
Deciding the facts of his life from such writings is a bit of a challenge.
In fact,
this lack of solid biographical information is actually known as the Socratic
problem.
Socrates was either born in 469 or 470 BCE in a Greek village located at 20
minute walk away from Athens.
His father,
[inaudible] was a sculptor while his mother [inaudible] worked as a midwife.
Software discuss wants it his son to take on the craft of a sculptor.
So during his youth he was apprentice to his father.
He apparently became an accomplished sculptor with tradition having it that he
worked on a well named statue entitled for three muses in their habits which was
displayed at the Acropolis.
As a young man,
Socrates devoured the writings of the Greek philosopher and exaggerates.
It is believed that he may have actually studied under this master,
but this cannot be determined with certainty.
The basic teachings all that Xander is that all things have always existed,
puts in their original form were in tiny fragments of that current form in
Athens.
The [inaudible] Gora or public square was the central meeting place for men who
would discuss politics,
art,
and philosophy as even still a youth.
Socrates was not able to attend the or Gora.
Instead,
he spent much of his free time in the workshops of the city's merchants where he
would engage them in philosophical questioning.
After some time working as a sculptor,
Socrates went off to study under the philosophical master [inaudible].
He studied mathematics and destroy enemy and became familiar with the work of
earlier philosophers.
According to a third century biographer by the name of [inaudible] latest Oculus
embarks upon they homosexual relationship with Socrates,
a practice which was widespread in ancient Greece.
At the time that Socrates began showing an interest in philosophy,
the discipline was about a hundred years old.
The idea is the word being thrown around web largely theoretical bearing,
little practical application.
Socrates soon came to the realization the other things that he was learning.
They didn't really have any benefit to society.
He was far more interested in addressing the problems of everyday life despite
his curiosity to understand the world.
He was not a scientific thinker.
Rather than questioning the weld,
do understand how it worked.
He believed that we would be better off questioning ourselves in order to
understand how we work.
He adopted the quote,
which has often been wrongly attributed to him and that's know thyself.
With the outbreak of the Peloponnesian war in 431 BCE,
Socrates was recruited as a hoplite.
The equivalence of a private third class immediately stood out among his fellow
conscripts even though there is much discrepancy about the details of his life.
There is one thing about Socrates upon which there is universal agreement and
that's what he was ugly.
He had a snub nose and is how it was long and uncapped.
He also showed no interest in personal grooming and there's also rally bathed.
We know about Socrates military service from the writings of Plato in Plato's
work apology,
he tells us that his master fought in the battles of amphib Willis deleon.
I'm in Potter Diet and other chronic Alaa.
Alison by artists specifically mentioned Socrates,
heroic actions in the bachelor of deleon stating that the philosopher saved his
life during the fighting having completed his military service in foreign during
six BCE,
Socrates was appointed as a member of the Bul,
which was a 500 member council,
which ran the daily affairs of Athens is the uniform,
tells us that he was the overseer of a debate that was held to determine the
fates of a number of military commanders who abandons their wounded in battle in
order to pursue the Spartans.
The public were clamoring for the men's we put to death,
but Socrates,
he blocked the vote and he sped the men's lives
with the ends of the Peloponnesian war in 404 BC,
there was a period of upheaval in Athens that resulted in the coming to power of
a group known as the 30 tyrants.
These men instituted a period of terra marked by bloodshed and confiscation of
property.
After eight months,
the rebel regime,
Fallon was replaced with a democratic Greek governments,
but that hardly meant that life was going to get better for Socrates.
In fact,
it was mounted to get a whole lot worse.
Socrates was an opponent of democracy.
He believed that the people as a whole and capable of self rule,
they needed a wise shepherd to guide them in their lives.
He further claims that the ordinary citizen did not possess any native virtue
that would given them the ability to speak on behalf of others.
Virtue he maintained was something that is attained only by knowledge,
and that knowledge was beyond the scope of the everyday person.
These ideas,
as they were sharply at odds with those of the Athenian Society in which
Socrates lived,
that people cherish the enlightened right of every citizen having a voice in the
assembly.
As a result of the ideas of Socrates were viewed with suspicion if not outright
hostility.
Things weren't helps by the rather condescending and arrogant manner in which
she expressed his views.
He was dismissive of those who held views country to his own.
This frequently lead violent reactions dodge these records is that men set upon
him with their fists or tore his hat out paced with this Socrates bull.
All this ill usage patiently.
A fascinating contemporary view of Socrates is provided by the Athenian comic
playwright Aristophanes in 423 BC he wrote a play called of the clouds and that
play is a character who is clearly based on Socrates.
This character,
the headmaster of a thinkery,
is presented as a comic buffoon who stalks the streets.
Beth was looking down his nose that the ignorant masses and Andrew are rolling
his eyes at the unintelligible guttural murmurings that he hears.
Socrates was apparently friendly with Aristophanes and held no grudge against
such betrayals.
In fact,
please saw quite to saying the following when they break adjust upon me in the
theater,
I feel as if I were at a big party of good friends.
It beers then that around the four twinsies Socrates was seen by most people as
a local audible who was slightly annoying but generally harmless,
but well that view,
it was about of change.
The democracy.
The Athenians so cherished,
it was challenged on two occasions during Socrates,
later years during a full month periods in for 11 to four 10 BCE,
Athenian democracy.
It was overthrown.
Then in 404 BCE,
the 30 tyrants,
you subbed to democracy ushering in eight months of chaos.
Both of these insurrections were led by former students of Socrates,
Alison [inaudible],
and Critias relatives of Plato.
The first is that these insurrections turns public opinion against Socrates as
the brains behind the coup with the bloodshed caused.
By the seconds over three people began to indirectly blame the philosopher for
the carnage.
With the coming to power,
the 30 tyrants,
the former leaders of the democracy fled to the mountains.
It was that that they plans their resistance.
The elders of the new totalitarian government did not directly involve Socrates
in the carrying out of their wicked act.
Six steps on one single occasion.
They summoned him along with four other men and ordered them to go to Salamis
and apprehends,
a learned man of influence by the name of Leon and then bring him back to Athens
to be executed.
This man was an upstanding on a citizen who had done nothing deserving of
condemnation,
let alone death.
Socrates refuse to do this daddy whack,
stating that he would never perform an act that compromised his integrity.
However,
he didn't do anything to warmly on of the impending danger.
As a result of the other four men went ahead and was apprehended Leon and he was
summarily put to death.
This failure to proactively,
warmly on it would come back to home Socrates,
that is upcoming trial rather than being viewed as the local eccentric.
Socrates was now being seen by many as a dangerous spreader of radical ideas
that were leading others to the most vile accesses.
In 403 BCE,
the rule of the 30 tyrants was over and they form a democratic government had
been restored,
a general assembly had been enacted,
which meant that no one including Socrates could be brought up on charges of
their actions during the eight months of tyranny.
Now,
just before we get into the downfall of Socrates,
I do want to briefly talk about today's sponsor.
Brilliant.
I know as always these ads in the middle less than awesome but brilliant,
fantastic for sponsoring this sort of longer content because it allows us to
share these stories of some of the world's greatest historical thinkers,
brilliance or a science learning platform that will allow you to learn through
active learning,
which sums up is basically the opposite of that healing and reading a bunch of
complex information about some principal is just having it go completely over
your hat and brilliant.
Don't just deal with the basics or they,
they do cover that as well.
They go all the way through to very complex things like advanced statistics.
Brilliance have a relatively new feature.
It's called daily problems and it's five minutes a day that you can use to
exercise your brain and then something new.
Each problem provides you the context and a framework you need to tackle it.
That means you can learn concepts by applying them.
That's that active learning.
This sort of short daily practice can lead you from curiosity to mastery in far
less time than you might think I've been using.
Brilliant.
It's excellent.
That should go try it out.
It just,
even if it's just to see how quickly you can understand those complex subjects,
you can support this show by going to brilliant.org forward slash biographics
and now let's get on with our exploration of Socrates's life.
Socrates was finally arrested in 399 BCA.
By then,
the stage is how to four years since the end of the last revolt to come up with
some charges against him.
During that period,
Socrates,
they had to be undeterred by the returns,
the favor of democracy and the antipathy towards those who espoused views and
opposition to it.
He continued to deride democracy and champion rule by a strong leader when there
was another attempt to overthrow in 401 the state that had enough of is
revolutionizing of the impressionable youth.
It was now just a matter of time before he was brought to account the Athenian
law allowed for any citizens to bring criminal proceedings against another man.
Imagine names Mellitus brought an oral summons against Socrates.
The summons required him to appear before a legal magistrates faced charges of
impiety and corrupting the youth.
The magistrate heard out the applicants and determines that the were grounds for
a preliminary hearing.
At that hearing,
the charges were read out and Socrates was given the opportunity to answer them.
Uh,
documents containing the challenges was drawn up along with the requested
penalty.
It reds.
Socrates is guilty of refusing to recognize the gods recognized by the state and
to introducing new divinities.
He has also guilty of corrupting the youth.
The penalty demanded his death.
The actual trial took place over a period of nine hours in the [inaudible] Gora
in the center of Athens.
The Jerry was made up of 500 citizens drawn by lot.
The large number was standard in ancient trials seem to have been mainly to
prevent bribery from swaying the outcome of cases after the reading over the
challenges,
the three main accuses of Socrates were given three hours to present a case.
There is no surviving record of their testimony,
but we do know that the main accuser was not Mellitus,
but a certain Anitas Itas who was also a politician who harbored ongoing
resentments against Socrates.
It is believed that the sign of an Itas was a student with him,
Socrates that had a homosexual relationship,
something which greatly upset the father.
It is likely that the main thrust of the accusations was that Socrates was
leading young people down a dangerous political path with his anti democratic
teachings.
How are the,
in Plato's apology in which he provides an accounts of Socrates as defense,
considerable weight has given to his defense of the charge of impiety.
Piety in those days involve not only respect for the Greek gods,
but also for the dead and for one's ancestors.
If there was even one in pious person in the city,
it was a serious matter is that one's incursions might bring the wrath of the
gods upon the entire city.
Even though the Athenians have no written scripture or code and no priesthood,
there was a significant number of rituals,
observances,
and offerings that were required.
It is highly likely that Socrates neglected to observe the rituals of the gods
that would have been expected of him.
Furthermore,
he would have argued that the generally accepted view of worship as being based
on rituals was wrong.
According to Zena Font,
Socrates had the ability to communicate directly with the gods.
This would have been infuriated.
Those in attendance that is trialing polluting the 500 jurors.
It is difficult for us to know just what if any religious beliefs Socrates
actually held throughout his dialogues.
Plato has him referring to both at one gods and also to plural gods.
It has also been suggested that he viewed the word God is referring to the
philosophical idea of goodness,
a critical parts of the accusations against him,
how to do with his place association with the leaders of the 30 tyrants
rebellions,
specifically his ties to the leader of the revolt Critias and his defense.
Socrates brought up the time when he was ordered to go into rascally and of
Salamis.
He claims that his refusal to do so.
It was a clear indication that he was not in cahoots with the rebels and was
indeed a loyal citizen of Athens.
His accused accounted that a loyal citizen would have done more than simply
refrain from the bad action.
He would have warned in the innocent man and is therefore saved his life.
So critiques spoken his own defense for three full hours of the dozens of
versions of it that were made only to have survive down to our time.
Those of Plato and Xenophon diversions agree that the master was defined in his
tone almost as if he were inviting and adverse judgments as positive as defense.
Socrates told the jurors that he was a hero.
He recalls his exemplary military service.
He then extended the thought with an analogy,
telling them that he had fought for decades to save the souls of Young
Athenians.
If teaching virtue made him guilty of corruption,
he said then that he was guilty as charged.
He then assured his lesson as with the following men of Athens,
I honor and love you,
but I shall obey God rather than you.
And when I have life and strength,
I shall never cease from the practice and teaching a philosophy in the face of
the challenges that he was a corruption of the youth of Athens.
Socrates stated that he never claimed to be a teacher.
He was merely a man who happened to spend time strolling around the city.
If he was asked a question,
he would answer it to the best of his ability.
Then pointing to place her and others of his followers in the crowd.
He pointed out that none of them had have a lead and accusation against him.
Those of his former students who had done that,
he said did so because they corrupted the things that he had set as the marathon
speech drew to a close.
It was obvious to everyone listening that Socrates said,
no intention of stopping doing whatever it was that the people objected to.
The only way to stop him,
we still put him to death.
Contrary to normal practice in such proceedings,
he made no please for any mercy.
After nine hours of proceedings,
the jury of 500 were tasked with making that decision.
Unlike today,
the jury did not retire to discuss their thoughts.
They simply voted by placing a disk and one of two Ns labeled guilty or not
guilty with the urn that held the most votes determining the outcome when
they've completed this task.
There were 280 desks in the guilty on and 220 in the not guilty one,
but the jury's job.
It was not yet over.
They had to determine the penalty.
The accusers of Socrates rose and put forward their case that the condemned
impious corruptor of the youth of Athens must be put to death.
Socrates himself was then invited to put forward a case for leniency.
This was his opportunity to win some favor with the jury,
perhaps by suggesting that he'd be sent into exile.
Boss treat who isn't him.
He refused to step down from his position of superior indignation.
He should.
He suggested to be rewarded rather than condemned for his actions.
The court officials,
they were not impressed and he was told to give a more realistic alternative
penalty.
Socrates then offered that he could be subjected to a modest fine faced with
these two extremes of punishments.
The jurors,
they chose death
with the trial.
Now I have a Socrates was taken to an adjoining prison cell.
According to the records of his final days,
pen the by Plato.
Socrates was given the opportunity to escape when he was visited in a cell by
his wealthy friend Creattech.
This man has already laid plans to smuggle Socrates out of Athens.
However,
the condemned man showed no interest in escaping his fate.
The conversation between the two men as Credo attempted to persuade Socrates to
escape and the great philosophers responses presents an important aspect of
Socrates as moral code.
Criso put forward three points as to why Socrates should escape from his death
sentence.
First lead the death would be a bad reflection on the followers of Socrates's.
People would think that they'd abandoned him.
Secondly,
or finances involved in the escape were covered and furthermore,
a comfortable life in exile had been arranged.
Finally,
his death would leave his sons without a father.
In response.
Socrates countered the demand should not worry about public opinion,
but only be guided by wisdom.
The only real question to consider in the situation was whether or not it was
just for Socrates.
Do escape his condemnation to death.
He then spoke of the laws of Athens stating this to break one of those laws
meant breaking them all to go against the laws of Athens would be like a child
rebelling against a parents.
He argued if he dad to go against the laws of the city here started,
he would receive a harsh and judgments in the underworld.
As a result,
Socrates refused the offer,
escape his face.
It was now sealed,
plays a chronicled his death and his walk dome and it's,
he gives an eye witness accounts from the viewpoint of the fictional character,
a fito.
According to the accounts,
a man came into the cell carrying a cup of poison hemlock.
Socrates turns to him and said,
now,
good sa,
you understand these things.
Tell me what I must do.
The man replied,
just drink it since.
Walk around until your legs begin to feel heavy.
Then lie down.
It will soon act.
The Cup was then offered to Socrates.
You took it happily and asked if it was permissible for him to offer a pledge
before drinking as permission was granted and z offered the following prayer,
we can and must praise the gods of the tall so Joan on earth will continue happy
beyond the grave.
This is my prayer and it's May it come to pass at this,
he drank the poison without hesitation,
those of his friends who were in the cell with him,
gateway to tears prompting Socrates to declare you are strange fellows.
What is wrong with you?
I send the women away for this very purpose to stop.
They're creating such a scene.
I have herbs that one should die in silence,
so please keep quiet and to keep control of yourselves for the next few minutes
he walked around the room.
Then when his legs became heavy,
he laid down on his badge with a covering over his face solely.
He lost feeling first and his legs then moving up his body.
His last words directed credo a credo.
We owe a cock to Asclepius do pay it.
Don't forget,
this seems around the strange request,
but it makes sense when we realized that Asclepius was the god of good health,
the sacrifice of a caucus and normal offering for thanks for recovery from
illness.
Socrates believed that he was cured of the disease of life and was as a result,
not frightened of death creature than ostium.
If there was anything else you wanted to say,
but there was no reply.
The poison had reached his hot and was the life of Socrates was drained away.
Plato continued his accounts with these words.
This was the end of our friends,
the best,
wisest,
and most upright man of any that I have ever known.
So I really hope you found this video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos like this several times a week,
so hit that subscribe button to find out about all of those.
Also feeling of something else to watch right now.
Why not check out my other channel called today.
I found out you'll find a link to that in the description below.
And as always,
thank you for watching.